je vous le disais en titre ce coup de
tonnerre politique à tour la première
adjointe au maire cathy munch masse est
mise en cause dans une affaire de
détournement de fonds son mari aurait
siphonné 350000 euros de l'association
pour personnes handicapées qu'il gérait
la page 6 sur le volet détournement
toute complicité de l'élu est écarté une
partie de l'argent en revanche bien
atterri sur le compte commun du couple
placé depuis sous contrôle judiciaire
les détails avec aurélie rhône
la page est une association
d'accompagnement des personnes
handicapées guillaume assez dirige
l'association depuis 2010 est à la suite
de son épouse cathy munch masse et la
première adjointe de la ville de tours
dans un communiqué de presse le
procureur de la république indique
aujourd'hui que guillaume assez
reconnaît les faits qui lui sont
reprochés il a encaissé 24 chèque d'un
montant de 350 mille euros au total en
établissant de fausses factures l'argent
transitait pour partie sur le compte
joint du couple pour apurer
d'importantes dettes guillaume assez
indiqué aux enquêteurs qu'il a agi seul
selon lui son épouse n'était pas au
courant en effet durant sa garde à vue
cathy munch masse est contestée
l'intégralité des faits qui lui sont
reprochés
les époux sont convoqués devant le
tribunal correctionnel de tours en
février prochain guillaume masse et sera
jugé pour chefs de faux usage de faux et
abus de confiance au préjudice de
l'association
cathy munch massés pour recel d'abus de
confiance aggravé leur sel ça veut dire
que la justice en l'occurrence le
parquet puisque c'est le parquet qui
décide d'aider poursuite estime qu'elle
n'a pas directement participé à
l'infraction d'abus de confiance mais en
revanche qu'elle en a peut-être et ce
sera toute la question qui se posera
devant le tribunal correctionnel
profitez sciemment ou inconsciemment le
la justice estime que quand un abus de
confiance est commis au détriment d'une
association qui a
notamment l'espèce vocation à aider des
handicapés si cette association est
victime d'un abus de confiance c'est une
circonstance aggravante et la peine
encourue alors la peine encourue c'est
pas la peine qui sera prononcée
mais la peine maximum encourue est de
sept années de prison après ce coup de
tonnerre politique pas de prise de
parole devant nos caméras aujourd'hui de
la part de la mairie de tours par voie
de communiqué le maire fait savoir que
l'élu soupçonné d'avoir bénéficié des
fonds détournés par son mari est
suspendu de ses délégations une
suspension immédiate
le groupe d'opposition de droite lui
demande à katy mutsch menacé de
démissionner